after two and a half years of denying
its very existence north korea seems not
only to have accepted the arrival of the
pandemic but that it's now everywhere
the outbreak dominates extended coverage
on state-run media with people being
encouraged to adopt good hygiene
exercise and home-grown remedies
with the emphasis on living with the
virus rather than isolating from it
the malignant virus spreads very quickly
but on the other hand the danger of the
pathogen is low it can be completely
destroyed
case studies of families who have
apparently contracted the virus and then
recovered have been widely aired
we all got sick this father says then
adding they all got better within a
couple of days
the message seems to be don't panic
it's very different from the confident
face that north korea has shown to the
world in public parades and gatherings
in recent months which could prove to
have been major super spreader events
leader kim jong-un has criticized his
officials and ordered pharmacies to
provide more medicines given most people
experience mild symptoms from the
omicron variant it's been established
that cold and flu remedies can help but
that's on top of comprehensive
vaccination campaigns and so far north
korea has resisted all international
offers of vaccines including from south
korea this mild type of kovid 19
spreading through a completely
unprotected population seems to be
uncharted territory with neighboring
health officials looking on with concern
we don't know what the consequences of
this omicron variant will be when it
spreads to a large number of people who
have never been in contact with covid19
there are enough reasons to pay
attention to this with interest
adding to north korea's problems is
widespread malnutrition from food
shortages
an economy racked by years of sanctions
and a weak medical system many observers
believe it can't afford a hard lockdown
like other countries and has no choice
but to tough it out rob mcbride al
jazeera seoul